You know everybody welcome to another zoom call a few housekeeping things to remind you about
Remember always to go to the members only site at
The main page of the members only site you'll see their announcements and we did some changes to the self-scheduling
so
Act to our old prices or done
There was a period of time that we gave everybody done member or member prices for just the office visits
To help people out there
You know recessional times and we just had to go back to our regular prices on that
So there's it's just difficult to manage having two self-scheduling things out there
So if you members can just call in for your appointments, you could still get the discounted price
But if you went to the self-schedule page on our website and you self-scheduled and paid
We can't schedule without paid and you'd have paid a higher price and then we'd have to refund you
So it's just easier if you call in the schedule of your appointments
Okay, so first question. Let's jump into it
I've been researching chlorine dioxide
Which used to be called MMS
Miracle mineral solution or something like that. I purchased some pre-made solution
Do you think there is any reason not to consume this throughout the day with the protocol and currently on?
I've been back to daily and fed men for days on three days off
So you know just having this question on
our if I posted this video just
Just say those words chlorine dioxide and we posted this to YouTube
YouTube would ban us that's how we got somebody strikes on YouTube and somebody asked a question about chlorine dioxide
So we'll make sure we don't post this video to to YouTube. It's just so sad. I mean, they say that they're not you know
Doing this anymore. They're still doing it just as much. It's just ridiculous
Okay, so what is chloride dioxide chlorine that dioxide is a chlorine solution? So
It's not chlorine that you would buy in the store, but it's similar. It's just one
molecule away
One animal away from it being chlorine. So it is still a caustic substance, and that's how it can work
it is a
oxidative substance
Now if you read my article hard to see an oxidative stress to kill cancer in the blog. We'll see that there's
That different nutrients are oxidative at different doses
So high dose vitamin C is oxidative
Lodos vitamin C is is an antioxidant
Hydose vitamin E is oxidative low dose vitamin E is
antioxidant
Same thing with melatonin same thing with selenium the same thing with multiple other supplements
Plus a lot of other supplements that our cancer killing supplements
And have been you know having cancer
Quarant cancer killing properties over the years like like
Vitamin B17 and you know, high dose different herbs like the hoxy type herbs and seacurbs
They work because they're oxidative now chloride dioxide is an oxidative
Substance to so would it be good for cancer? Yes in a sense? Yes in a high dose. It would be good for cancer
The only negative of that is that
Whereas high dose
Or the missing it or high dose vitamin C or high dose B17
Will kill cancer cells, but it tends to spare
Healthy cells. So high dose selenium
It's never going to hurt anybody. It's not going to cause cancer because it's oxidative
It's not going to cause cancer to healthy cells whereas chemotherapy is oxidative
And it will kill cancer cells, but it can actually cause cancer to healthy cells and it can kill healthy cells
Because it doesn't spare healthy cells
Well chloride dioxide doesn't spare healthy cells either
I have her back dead and bed is all work on a different pathway
They don't work to kill cancer because they're oxidative
They work to kill cancer for different pathways the main pathway
I believe is that it up regulates the p53 to where suppressor gene pathway
chloride dioxide can be beneficial for cancer patients because it's oxidative
But it doesn't spare healthy cells so it can damage healthy cells
That is typically why we don't typically recommend it for cancer patients
Now back in the day when we used to see a lot of line patients
We had a lot of people on chloride dioxide because it could be really beneficial to kill pathogens
It could kill
Lime in its co-infections
So it can be beneficial that way
So by all means you can take it if you want to
And the question really is, is it going to
negatively affect your current protocol?
I would say no, it's not going to negatively affect your current protocol
It's working a completely different pathway than either back to the bed bed is all
And it's working on a different pathway
than any of your other supplements you're own
Besides coffee enemas, what's the best
non-invasive way to detoxify the liver?
Well you could go back to this seven phases of detox course
that you all have access to if you really want to understand this because
you're supported detoxification of the liver with different herbs, different supplements
than I have you on
And again, it's not just detoxification of the liver, it's everything does stream from the liver
Are you helping decrease the viscosity of bile to help bile flow?
So it doesn't get clogged up in your gall bladder
Are you helping with your bowel movements so that you're able to make sure that you're not holding
your feces too low and a reabsorbing stop?
Are you using binders so that you don't reabsorb stop
and put things right back into the bloodstream and put more stress on your liver?
So you know the other things that you know you could do or things that we've talked about before
you see casterol packs over your liver putting hot packs over your liver
you know those are you know
kinds of things that can be very beneficial for
helping support your liver pathways
besides different herbs and nutrients that are supporting phase one phase two phase three
I had to stop my fed bend and I've erected protocol because 19 D numbers were too high
but my my blood analysis practitioner still sees parasites in my blood
so he wants me to try to albendazole 400 milligrams twice a day but only one day a week
I read that you need to keep an eye on your liver numbers for this medication also
but I'm wondering if this dosage at this frequency is small enough
that I should not have to worry about it
well again there's no way that anybody can say yes or no to that
you'd have to keep an eye on your numbers so if the fed bendazole is what is causing too much
of a rise in your kidney numbers the albendazole is going to do the exact same thing
so it's in that same family it's going to do that same thing
so but because you're only doing it once a week maybe that would help well maybe yeah
the only way to know is to look at your blood work again so you know that that's the only way
to answer that question regarding the radiation drops following a path scan
I have half a bottle of drops left should I order another and is the dosage just a few drops a day
last week you'd ever got to the dosage part just that I don't need to take them beforehand
and to finish the bottle yeah so just follow the dosage that's right on the bottle
so I think it's you know if it's the drops from us it's the three drops twice a day if it's the
radaline from um professional health products I think it's 30 drops twice a day if a mistake and
just follow those the dosage that's on the bottle and then I have made mention that you just
finish the bottle so if you have a half a bottle left from a previous scan if that's what you're saying
then could you just finish that half a bottle maybe you know maybe I mean in truth I mean
you could take the radiate anybody even if you've never had radiation could take the radiation drops
because you're exposed to radiation so well how am I exposed to radiation I haven't gotten the
next right I haven't gotten you know the PET scan I haven't got the CT scan there's radiation everywhere
you're being exposed to radiation so you could be you could benefit from taking the radiation
homeopath even if you didn't do those type of therapies or scans so um I'm just trying to prevent
you anybody from having to take too many things and um but to you know to make sure you're you're doing
the best to help rid your body of that then by all means get another bottle and finish you know
bottle in a half so it's just going to help with that there's no magic spot in where you're you know
you're ever going to be completely clean so you do your best the best you can you mention that we
should not be on our phones when using the right machine how about if we have a sticker or device
on the phone that changes the unhealthy way the EMFs affect us will this still interfere with the
right frequencies specifically on the air's tech device on my phone well technically or technically
you could be on your phone when you're doing the right okay so the the frequencies from your phone
are not going to be powerful enough to to change or alter the frequencies that are coming out of the
so it's not going to harm the treatment frequencies you're not going to have a negative effect on
the treatment frequencies from the right machine by using your phone um it's you know is it
best to not be you don't have multiple frequencies coming at you you have probably be better but
you know I'll be the first to be honest and say I sometimes am on my phone when I'm running
the right I mean sometimes at work when I'm running the right I'm on my computer so I mean you
just do your best it the best you can don't ever think that anything you're going to do is get a
negatively effect the frequencies coming out of the right because that's coming out in a much
stronger power than anything that you're that's coming out of your phone so um you you're not
going to have a negative effect on the right I'm just saying that it might be better for you
this is a similar question we'll have it a CPAP machine running during the night that is right next
to my head interfere with the frequencies on the right again there's nothing that you could do that
could interfere with the frequencies on the right so no you don't have to worry about that I am
taking the Michael pole and the biotoxin binder as you suggested the instructions from your office
said to take it about half hour away from food in the afternoon how far away from supplements should
I take it since it has charcoal in it too you're probably a better off keeping it at least an hour
away from supplements um and it would be better if you kept it an hour away from food so
um you just have to be reasonable but if you can find that time you know I have some patients that
were like they won't eat you know two hours before they go to bed and then they'll take these right
before they go to bed that's something doable too you got to find what's doable in your life
some people it's more difficult because they're working all time and it's trying to find the time
to take different things and they have to kind of figure it out from themselves it's best if you
could take those two supplements any binders it'd be best if you could take it an hour away from food
or supplements on either side but then you're that's a two hour window that you're not eating if
you're able to tolerate that I have an unopened bottle of liquid multiminns called uh aqueous
multi plus from biotics research there is no folic acid or folated it is it okay to take
I know they are higher and brand but just wanted to check um but I'm familiar with that product
but I would say no I mean that has copper in it it has cyanocabolumine in it um I don't think it's a
great supplement um so I don't think it's a great supplement for anybody I don't I don't you know
get a lot of these companies we we sell a lot of biotics research and I think a lot of their products
are really really good but I do think that sometimes you know there isn't any supplement company
that I think all their products are good I'll just tell you that right now um it it it makes me
scratch my head like why in the world are you selling this with this in it you know uh sometimes it's
because that was it that's an older supplement it might have been introduced in 1990s or something
when the knowledge was more limited and they and they have a lot of doctors that still buy it
so they keep selling it and then um and then sometimes supplement companies have
uh they hire a doctor to be their um you know their chief of staff that is going to help
with formulations that isn't really good and then they start introducing products that
why are you introducing that uh because they're kind of fan type product products
in their good companies like Zymanjit and Orthomolecular designs for health and standard process
I mean good to say standard process took forever they would you know it would they would fight with
the whole gluten they they you know 90 95% of their supplements have gluten in them and they just would
not they still haven't changed now they have some in their life that are gluten free but they
wouldn't change because they just wouldn't change with the times um so it's yeah it's it's difficult
so that you know you have to cherry pick you know even good companies don't necessarily all have good
supplements i mean cyanokabone why in the world you have a product with cyanokabone
in it that makes absolutely no sense in the way the other minerals in this product are are bound
it's just it's not a natural product so i would not use that product sorry
on Sunday indeed and Monday i ran the frequencies for trauma and then the frequencies for the parasite
hilarious later in the afternoon i felt like i was on speed it was very uncomfortable
i just talked it up to taking my v vitamins to late the day i did however feel tremendous release
from the trauma frequency and have felt joy for the first time in years this is a huge this is huge
for me and a huge praise report will praise god for that uh this mordid i did the trauma
and the hilarious frequency again after also doing that last evening i had not eaten anything no
caffeine no albuterol or no do supplements the wired speed feeling like feeling started about 30
minutes after i finished the frequencies my pulse was normal uh but i am still swirly to my brain
and feel very uncomfortable um do i have do you have any thoughts on what this might be um should i
do the frequencies once a day or every other day to prevent this yes so there's times that you
could run parasites frequencies and you could get these symptoms i think it's from the parasite
frequencies so because you can have parasites in your head so um it could uh the die off can affect
this can cause this so you could get die off and you could get glutamate release in your brain
with a die off and that's probably what's doing it so glutamate is an excitatory or a transmitter and
that's most likely what's happening so but it's all good but you can't you got to be careful
on how much you do because you don't want to overdo it you have to be able to clear that glutamate
out ultimately so you've got to give yourself some time so either spread out the times that you do
this meeting like you're going to do it every three days or maybe you're going to do it once a week
or choose to do it for a less amount of time each time so you can stop the program after a period of
time and see if that makes a difference like the program is 20 minutes you're on you do 10 minutes
you know you've got to choose maybe only do it once a week the whole program so I had a pick and choose
and play with what makes you feel better so it's all good things but you've got to let your body detox
to what is the best glucometer to buy are the not invasive ones okay yeah you could buy any glucometer
on the market um yeah I just personally I have only used the finger prick ones that you could buy
at Walgreens or Target or Walmart um they're up you know maybe 35 40 dollars they come with 100 sticks
um if you're not if you're doing it every day you know when you're checking your blood sugar every day
as a diabetic then certainly getting the the the thing that's attached to your arm then you're
checking it with an app on your phone is certainly less invasive and it certainly would be easier if
your hand diabetes at your monetary insulin levels um I would say that would be much you know easier
on you as far as having to prick yourself but if you're not treating in full diabetes treatment
right now and you're just wanting to check your blood sugar maybe you know four times a week to
begin with and down to twice a week or something it's pretty easy to do a finger prick so I think I
would probably go that route questions from the chat last time you did a cheek swab I included a
capsule each of the doctor cheek products I was taking for future cheek swabs do I include them again
I'm sorry you will um because I threw them so um I could save them that this time I apologize um just
to remind me with a note please say for future cheek swabs and if you did that I apologize um for
tossing it I'm getting a sample of one of those patches that people are selling these days is this
something that you could muscle test for me do you think if it does good does test good for me
will it alter the other supplements in my program so there's these little patches maybe some of
you guys are using these frequency patches you know they're used I don't know how many companies
sell them now used to be a multi-level company that came out with them I don't know it was a long time
ago probably 10 years ago and they were a big fan for a while and they're supposed to give you
you could get the energy patch or the detox patch or the glutathione patch or the this patch or
the not patch or whatever um and they're supposed to have the frequency of that thing that they're
trying to do embedded in it in it was then supposed to help you now I have had patients that swear
by them and say I'd use the energy patch of that really helped with my energy and hey who might
say that that doesn't work you know whatever um I would just say and be really careful you know because
there's all sorts of companies that are supplement companies that are therapy companies that are
these type of companies that they have zero liability for lying through their teeth so I would just
be careful with those things can it be helpful for someone maybe good as aches I mean literally I
could muscle test you and probably 100 supplements that could be helpful for you is it wise to take
them all no you have to cherry pick what's going to be the best thing so when I'm doing
hideziology on you honestly the chance of those patches helping you with the type of hideziology
that I'm going on your cheek swab is almost next to zero because I'm locking into cancer so I'm not
just doing kiteziology for general welfare for you I'm doing it specifically for cancer so the
chance that those are going to help for cancers probably pretty slim certainly you can send a sample I
could check but I'm just saying that that's probably pretty slim um you know there's you know they're
not frequencies for that so um but I'm not against using them if you feel like you want to use them
but I know I've seen different videos out there people say you know they're obviously somebody who's
you know some monkey muck in the company that's making some claim that oh I started using these
and oh I don't have to take my supplements anymore because this this um um you know changed my
DNA or you know changed my metabolism now I don't have to do this and now I don't have to do this
I mean there's all sorts of gimmicky stuff out there you know from energy to weight loss to this
or that and you just have to be wise in everything you're doing um that you know there's a lot of
current-day snake oil salesman even in people that have I mean it's sometimes it's worse
that when people have MD degrees and stuff you know they're trying to get into the natural realm and
they literally know just I might do think about nutrition but since they have an MD and they could
use that to their advantage they can pretend that they're extremely knowledgeable and they can
push different products that they're that aren't very good so I'm not saying all of them are like
that but you just have to be careful with with with everything you know this is what I've shared with
you guys before about this you know the positives the negatives of the internet the positives the
negatives of Instagram and Facebook is you know there's a lot of information that you could
glean and learn from and knowledge that you could gade but there's a lot of false stuff out there as well
um you know I have people sending me Instagram videos all the time asking me what do you think
about this and you watch it it's like you know some of it is all that's that's great you know there's
good information but that you know the majority of it is just like you've got to be kitty you know
they're just doing things to get followers to get something to sell you something um that's the
you just have to look at everybody's bias and um and my bias is well you look at everybody's bias
and then you weigh it out with logic and and and use reasoning the bible says come
reasoning together with me um that's why I love the truth of Christianity and biblical wisdom because
you can reason with it it's reasonable you can work through it you don't have to you know
have this blind faith you're having faith in a real god who loves us and wants to take care of us and
he tells us over and over again that we're not supposed to be ignorant it he desires us to be wise
knowledgeable and um that's you know where we should be spending most of our time learning so
okay next question I know a lady with severe autoimmune allergies etc that has had a host of miraculous
changes in a few days and it's reducing medications I was skeptical too but I can't ignore her
testimony so it got me curious to say the least absolute so I don't say and this
certainly shouldn't look into it so go ahead and look into it and give things a try maybe you'll be
in that classification of miraculous changes so um yeah any other questions what are your thoughts
about black sand so I assume you're asking about black sand the black sand the sand itself
so black sand is used it's blood root sand that is used topically to treat um melodomas and
squamous cell cancers and it is can be fantastic but you have to do your research it's not something
you just jump into and put black sand on it open breast wound or black sand on a melodoma without
looking at a bunch of videos there's a ton of videos online on YouTube different YouTube channels
I would say look at the two feathers product yeah that's one product um you could take it internally
yes it's um but I would use the black sand blood root capsules if you're going to take it internally
because um there uh it has granule and some other things in it too but um anyway yeah yes
you could use it topically you could use it internally um but you just have to be careful with it um
do your research on it before you um before you you take it make sure you know especially if you're
going to do the the topical make sure that you have um have looked at the videos and the websites out
there blacksam info.com is a good website where you could gather about your information about black sand
topical use as well. Okay well thank you guys for being on today and we will talk to everybody
next week all right bye bye